[Music]
1683 please 32-pound 28 please I'm
telling you boys
she was my loss at UI and seen him here
before is a resource disease owned were
lazy almost lost everything was a little
typed cash why is these days so well so
light Cheers
I need something to look forward to when
I get up in the morning I'm going to
breed a racehorse absolute madness he's
normally wealthy professionals you're
going for this kind of thing there's
ways that doing these things is net 20
people in the village put in a 10 or a
week for two years when the horse is
born everyone will be illness we'll all
have an equal share if you are good
enough to own a bloody racehorse
so am I it's a tenner every week curbing
[Music]
películas his knee we need to name what
about gleam Alliance is our dream I'm
rolling it together and so dream
alliance there's a less than 1% chance
this horse will ever win a race facing
the wrong way he keeps going in that
direction you'll end up back in the
village
[Music]
he's pretty rough around the edges
[Music]
governor he's definitely got something
about stearic character like his owner
be brave this is person to do we're
going to the races
[Applause]
[Music]
so proud of you seems like anything is
possible
the O's from nowhere has captured the
hearts of the nation
[Music]
we lost our jobs our community even our
pride and then dream came along and
reminded us what life is like when you
are cold
[Music]
[Music]